what about fighting the the chicken girl
fighting chicken date girl
hot [ __ ] hot chicken the chicken girl
the girl who the the white girl who
takes black people to eat chicken
yeah yeah
is that not a little weird a little bit
you know we said a few times
you know i was thinking it was a little
straight like because i saw that first
in america i was like hold on what's the
premise of this show
a white girl thinks black people eat
chicken like
[Music]
look how much these black people love
chicken this is going to make some great
content oh my god there's no way
you think there would be thought pieces
about this every single week in america
why does a white girl think she could
just take black people to eat chicken
every single week just watching them
lick their fingers and enjoy the god oh
my god where are you
it's just clicking my head like that
what are you thinking about taking black
dudes out for their two favorite things
a day with white women and fried chicken
she's doing the lord's work
in the uk where you think indians are
asians you get away with this type of
content
or you just like free chicken
i was like yeah that's great i mean
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
do it it was with jack harlow because
that one kind of resonated back home
obviously and i was like oh this girl's
like really funny and quirky and like
this is such an interesting show i
started looking at all the other ones
and it was just black people eating
chicken and i was like hold on now hold
on now
i know
i know you're not trying to give black
people
[ __ ] hypertension on youtube
it is wild dude
seen watermelon island
isn't that not crazy
she's such a nice ghost
she's sweet she's quirky and hilarious
but if i took only japanese people out
to sushi it would be a little bit
concerning right
everybody would ask the question at
least
why is this white guy
taking all these asians out to eat sushi
for no [ __ ] risk
oh my god oh my god that's [ __ ] it's
british fried chicken even that gut
oh yeah yeah bro come on bro
okay i got ray america as well like i
had popeyes the other day yeah oh
my god
come
it's like the thing out here it's like
the tgi fridays i guess or something
like that yeah it's like the chain is it
like the mediocre chain
but nando's not a black guy well
okay all right morley's i mean the
colonel he's like
i don't want to explain why
you try more these more this is i guess
molly's morley's yeah
[Music]
sidemen thing